we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail that came in hi
this is David from Lake Harmon
Pennsylvania well I was curious um if
Michael Flynn hasn't been sufficiently
vetted before the Trump administration
hired him any other high profile or high
position employees or staff and the
Trump administration also haven't been
vetted yeah I thought was an interesting
question God that only Michael Flynn's
vetting was a disaster are very very low
there is no doubt in my mind and I mean
even just just Jeff Sessions lied
multiple times about meetings with
Russians the idea that only Flynn
participate or was vetted in a way that
was kind of bogus III don't believe it I
think we'll learn about it well I think
an inherent issue to this to is that you
would have to vet other future officials
by officials who are already in the
positions that they're in and you were
not vetted themselves very good point
very good point so yeah i i i completely
agree with with the caller on the bonus
show today merriam-webster dictionary
has added the word sheeple to the
dictionary and it cites apple users as
an example leaked documents reveal that
facebook was conducting research to
target emotionally vulnerable and
insecure young people and congress does
the right thing by giving jeff sessions
zero dollars to go after medical
marijuana around the country how do you
get access to the bonus show very easy
you sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we do have a
coupon code available that coupon code
is I voted 17 and of course you can
always make a pledge of a couple of
bucks a month whatever works for you at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
will speak to you on the bonus show